Hello, I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich. This is radio lab, the podcast,
and today on our podcast we have four little stops we're going to make all
centered around that thing which none of us can avoid. That's coming for us all.
I'm talking of course about the big d. Well,
we all know we're going to die except some of our science friends.
Remember when we were at Harvard and we're talking to George Church,
George Church
professors genetics at Harvard medical school.
Are we doing this show about bioengineering?
Here's an example where we might grow up a large batch of of cells in a,
in a fermentor.
Yeah. George Church was the guy who was trying to use a little bacteria to make
gasoline a couple of liters. He is manipulating lives. Right?
He also flirts around with the idea of eliminating
the concept of death. I think. I think we,
I think I disagree that there is a quantum leap between living and nonliving.
I think there's a continuum between non-living and living and you can create all
sorts of, wait, wait. At some point, if I were to shoot you in the head. Yeah.
And you would fall on the floor with a hole in your head and bleed.
And I have no nurse or no doctor help you at some point,
good state will have changed fundamentally.
You'll stop breathing and you'll be over. Um, but I won't necessarily, yes,
you will be dead.
I'm saying that depending on the probability of a doctor coming into the room
and fixing me on the probability of more advanced technology and being able to
reverse the all kinds of pathological damage,
there's a value to saying that,
that there is a continuum between life and death.
And I can give you the continuum,
but I'm also thinking there will be a certain point in which you are
unmistakably over with current technology, uh,
but not necessarily with future technology. And, and there,
there may be you're saying that it is possible that you can never be totally
dead. That that might be a reversible state at some point. Well,
if we recorded the position,
all my atoms and we could recreate those position of all those Adams, uh,
you could completely burn me into Adams and then reassemble and isn't the,
isn't there? Isn't at the end, I'm alive again. I, yes,
I suppose in the conceptual, if you get to be really, really, really clever,
I guess you could re re reverse everything,
but maybe we could never get that clever or do you think that that, I mean,
I just, I, I think it's gonna boil down to cost. You know,
the idea of death implies that there is a sharp point at which you,
a point of no return. And I'm seeing this gets,
gets harder and harder and harder, um, and possible.
And I don't see that as particularly impossible. I mean,
if you've recorded the state of the living thing before it,
it starts going into this impossible decay.
If you just start from scratch and you build it from scratch,
nothing is really completely lost and nothing is completely gained.
The main thing that is retained through all this is the information
[inaudible]
and George Church thinks that being alive
is having all that information. So Jen,
if I knew where all your atoms are right now, you could always come back.
That's his view back.
That terrible thought for you, isn't it?
For my taste. There's a much more pleasant way to think about it. That's that.
Um, the other way to think about it is to think like Burt Heinrich,
a professor at the University of Vermont who got a curious letter and,
and a wonderful letter I think from a student of his named bill.
He was a grad student in entomology at UC Berkeley when I was teaching there.
And uh, he came out and, and visited at the camp in Maine.
Burn you see, has a cabin in, in,
in the western part of me and up on top of a mountain.
It's actually very beautiful set in the woods, a spruce and pine bill.
The Grad student did spend some time there and then he moved back to southern
California in a few years passed. And then this letter arrived.
Did you have any sense that there was anything wrong before you got the letter?
Or was this out of the
no, no, I had no sense whatsoever. No,
he was feeling hardy and then I got that letter.
So here's how the letter went. It begins. Yo Bernd.
I have been diagnosed with a severe illness and I'm trying to get my final
disposition arranged in case I drop sooner than I hoped.
I want an Abbey burial. This phrase,
happy burial refers to a guy named Edward Abbey who was a very,
very famous ecologist and who was brought into the desert by his best friends in
a sleeping bag when after he died and just put in the ground, no embalming,
no coffin,
lightly covered with sand and that's where they left him.
That is what bill wanted to have happen. Anyhow,
the upshot is he wrote one of the options is burial on private property.
What are your thoughts on having an old friend as a permanent resident at the
camp signed bill? In other words,
build wanted it to be laid out on the ground,
not even under the ground at burns place in Maine.
I wrote him a, I think a, I don't think I would,
I would want to have him laid out in front of my camp in Maine. I think that's,
uh, although, you know, uh, if it was a wilderness where, you know,
people are not going to be walking around, uh, then, uh, you know, I,
I would think more favorably of it.
I think right now I don't think we want to have carcasses lying around in the
woods. You know, I definitely don't think that,
but he did write bill this, he wrote,
I read you loud and clear when it's my turn. I too want no less for myself.
A casket would be for you as it was for Edward Abby,
an unacceptable cage for otherwise free and ever recycling molecules that would
soon become incorporated into the earth's ecosystem.
You know, I, I agree with the idea. I just feel that, you know,
being sealed up on totally removed all the natural processes that normally occur
with every animal on earth is very somehow frightening.
It's seems unnatural and I dunno, it just a,
it's funny that you'd use the word frightening.
I think most people lock themselves up in the casket because they're frightened
to be munched on by worms and beetles and things.
Yeah, no, I don't. I don't find that frightening at all.
I find that comforting to be part of the ecosystem, to be compost into grass,
to be compost into Ravens Doobie,
compost into flowers and trees. You know that,
that's a comforting thought to me.
[inaudible]
that's the other way to think about it is that you're releasing yourself for the
chance to be lots and lots and lots and lots of different do and more beautiful
lives that will succeed you, which I don't know. Wait, wait, wait.
I would say that if I could become plants,
new animals, what would that make you swoon? No,
it would make me feel like I'm like, I'm a collection of molecules.
I'm here for a season, 60 70 80 years, whatever,
and then I let my molecules go,
I disappear and the molecules go on to new adventures. Yeah, but that,
but then you're gone. You're gone. You're lost. Well,
the unit was here for 60 70 80 years, whatever is suddenly not here anymore.
And there isn't that an absence is a vacancy. Don't you feel that? I mean,
I love for the beetles and the things in the everyone to be
together again, but there is also the sense that when you disappear,
you're gone. You're done. I mean,
I understand on some level what George Church was saying to you. I mean, why,
if you've got the technology,
would you want to lose something so precious as a friend or a family member or a
lover or something or a cohost when you,
when you can bring that person back and, and you know what?
Forget us because it gets kind of egocentric when you're talking about bringing
yourself back. What about collections of ideas that are lost forever?
Like a language? I think the status,
like one language disappears every 14 days disappears from the earth never to be
spoken again because the last speaker of that language dies and then decomposes
and is eaten by the Beatles according to your fantasy. Well,
how would you be coped with them? Well, who knows, but we were talking to a guy,
David Eagleman, he's a neuroscientists.
I don't know what a neuroscientist would usually know about such things,
but he mentioned this thought experiment that has to do with lost language.
For example, nobody knows what Latin sounds like, right?
It's dead because all the people who spoke Latin,
there weren't tape recorders around when they were doing it.
And so essentially we all say, all right, that's, that's uh, it's dead.
It's gone.
But it turns out somebody made a proposal that probably wouldn't work,
but it was so stunning in its creativity, uh,
that I thought it was very interesting, which is he said, look,
sometimes these Roman pottery, if you can imagine these, uh,
wheels that turn these pottery wheels and you have a little stylists against the
piece of pottery, um, to make the line that spirals down.
He said, if there were people talking in the room while that was happening,
there might be micro vibrations that caused this stylist to move in and out.
And as a result, it essentially could act like a record.
And if you could play it back from these pieces of Roman pottery,
you could actually hear the people in the room talking in Latin. Ha,
well, fuck no.
Well, you could play a vase like a, like an LP, and then here like, um,
[inaudible] you know, the, the potter, you could hear his voice precisely.
Now the thing is it probably won't work exactly like that.
But what's interesting about the idea is that we're constantly coming up with
new technologies where then we can retrieve things that we once thought were
dead. [inaudible] W W in other words,
we thought the information sort of scattered off into the universe.
And then we're finding with the new technology,
we're able to bring it all back together. [inaudible] what was that?
We, those are, those are dead languages coming back. I don't know what that is.
It would probably [inaudible] for all those languages that were disappearing.
That's the Richard Gesture.
I was trying to evoke the sense of languages returning from the Cosmos and
brilliantly done brilliantly by all right. Smart Guy. You know,
if you want to stand for the proposition as you were earlier, that uh, you,
you'd be happy to decompose and become part of Mother Nature again in my time.
Well, that's what I was gonna ask you.
What if you had the choice right now to persist or let,
I don't know. I can't, obviously. We'll, okay.
Then let's end with a sort of owed to the persisters and this one comes from our
producer Ellen Horne,
so everybody's going to count them out. Okay. Set the scene for me.
Where are we? Well, we're,
we're near Wall Street and Manhattan and this is a CPR class.
It's a Sunday afternoon. Okay. Everybody ready? There's about 25 students here
and everyone's sort of basically pressing on dummies. Is that what's happening?
Yeah,
they crest in the middle of the chest 30 times 30 and then they tip the
mannequins head back can lift good and blow into the mouth twice.
But here's the central problem with doing CPR really well. It's the tempo.
You need to get the tempo right. If you do it too slow,
you don't get up enough pressure up to get the blood moving around the body.
And if you do it too fast, then the heart doesn't have time to fill back up.
And what's the ideal speed?
This hundred
beats per minute
and this class, the class, it's just learning CPR. It's hard to hear.
But if you listen
[inaudible]
just a little bit too fast.
And how exactly do you get people to do a hundred beats per minute?
That seems like abstract or something? Well, it's been shown,
if you ask people to think of a song,
they always remember it at the right tempo. Really. There's this guy,
Alison and Knob,
I'm a pediatric emergency medicine physician in Honolulu, Hawaii
teach a CPR. And he was trying to figure out a good way
to remember what a hundred compressions a minute should feel like when you're
doing CPR. So I thought find a song,
a popular song that had a beat of approximately a hundred beats per minute.
So what's the song on the song? He came up with,
uh,
help people stay alive.
Wow. And they did this, the class you went to,
this is caught fire CPR classes all over the world.
Egypt, Argentina, Botswana in Japan.
Using this to teach the right tempo of CPR
just happened to stumble upon it. And uh, it was a,
I think one of the best teaching tips I came up with in my career. So
there is another song though that's has a much simpler,
more direct downbeat, same tempo, same tempo.
And I asked the class to try this song
queen
another one bites the best. Oh, that's so wrong.
No one buys the dusty
[inaudible].
It's got a better beat in a way that then the death and it's certainly more
friends. Yes. But we should, we should let this cast die.
And speaking of which,
just want to urge you before we close to support your public radio station,
radio lobby's carried on more than 200 stations across the country.
You can check radio lab.org to see if your station carries us. If they do,
even if they don't, please consider making a gift to support that station.
Because without them, without you, we wouldn't exist.
Di Don't want to sty.
Radiolab is supported by the Sloan Foundation. Yes. Number One,
alphabet, peace loan. And number two, the National Science Foundation.
And number three, the corporation for public broadcasting.
I'm Jad Abumrad I rubber quote. Thanks for listening.